okay here are the questions Katey Porter
what do you think of Mitch McConnell
bragging that he will never bring up any
House bills in the Senate so I have a
favourite staffer you're not supposed to
have a favorite staffer it's like having
a favorite child but I have a favorite
staffer and she said I really want a pet
and I said absolutely no no no no we
can't even find our way out of the
emergency exit room like we know we
cannot take care of anything we kick it
and she said but I said what she said I
want a turtle and I want to name it
Mitch so I got her a stuffed turtle it
has a little tag on it it says hi my
name is Mitch asked me about my
legislative agenda so this is a real
problem I mean it's this is a problem
that on electing Donald Trump doesn't
itself solve right and so this is gonna
be with us potentially for for decades
to come this kind of legislative
roadblock okay Andrew Yang who do you
look most forward look who do you most
look forward to challenging in the
upcoming debates well I've said that I
have an 8% chance of standing next to
Joe Biden and and that's the plan
because I want America to Google Asian
man standing next to Joe Biden
[Laughter]
he is the front-runner yeah okay Bret do
you have any thoughts on YouTube
announcing that will take down videos
with extremist views well I don't know I
mean once you start opening that door
and this is what I've always said about
the censor Asst media machine is that
then once next it becomes this thing
where you cancel one person out and then
who's next Anna becomes just this
endless maze that you fall into so I was
not particularly I was kind of shocked
by it and upset by it and I also know a
lot of my friends on both sides of the
aisle were as well I don't think it's
anything that's going to move the Neil
forward or protect people or do anything
of the sort that it thinks it's trying
to do I hate to say it but I think the
big platforms are at this point begging
for government help and regulation on
figuring out what's free speech and
what's not because they're like why are
we making these decisions right but they
could be expected to do that I mean
there was a point when when the press
was with thought it was very much in
danger of having government regulation
and they stepped in oh the big media
company stepped in and said we're gonna
do this ourselves and we're gonna make
sure that we have some standards the big
tech companies could do the same thing
I'm not saying that we shouldn't have
federal regulation but I'm saying the
idea that they think that we're supposed
to be pitting them that they're we're so
helpless we can't do it on our own yes
you could do something and I think you
can do something with morals and values
in it that says the intent and that says
that we this is our value system as
companies and that that is a first step
though that they get from the government
is if there's a terrorist attack and we
tie it back to any of these things or
any other extremists what are we gonna
do we're gonna regulate you we're gonna
shut you down
so their response then is what they try
and move more towards censorship once
they can move towards censorship other
people say oh wait you can't censor that
content I can tell you just having more
counterterrorism for a very long time
what brought people together was the
internet and social media has really
accelerated extremism across the board
whether it's al Qaeda and Isis or white
nationalist terrorism we have now they
Network online they congregate
the operational plan online so there has
to be a balance in there I do think the
government needs to come up with some
sort of middle solution where they work
with the tech companies instead of
scolding in both directions depending on
what it is Charles do you think the 2020
census question will be shot down by the
Supreme Court now that we have proved
that Republicans designed it to
intimidate minority voters it's a great
question and not the question is on the
census but the because you proposed
[Laughter]
because it's I have no idea actually and
and we know both that by everybody who
studies the census and this is their job
that it is going to under count blacks
and minorities not just that question
but other alterations to the census as
well by one estimate we could have the
worst undercount since 1990 right we
know from that leaked material that they
intentionally try to do it to have an
undercount of blacks and minorities
blacks Hispanics particularly Hispanics
but the Supreme Court has been very
wobbly on this issue of whether or not
race is this still exists well and so I
don't know how they're gonna live on
this but no no exactly what the plan is
and how this thing but it don't tell us
a lot because that they look at that
evidence which is pretty smoking smoking
gun II and and still say you know what
too bad that's that's gonna tell us a
lot okay Andrew should Amazon follow
venture for America's model and open its
new headquarters in a city that could
use the economic boost and also I would
add to that what do you think about
breaking up the tech companies that's a
big issue Elizabeth Warren wants to do
it well there are absolutely excesses in
tech and our antitrust laws are our way
out of date they're using price as the
primary framework which doesn't work for
tech but the zeal to break them up is a
20th century solution to 21st century
problems none of us wants to use the
fourth-best navigation app there's a
reason no one is being anything
you know so so so saying that like hey
we just break them up and make them
compete against each other it's gonna
solve the problem it's not gonna solve
the problem and it's in some of the
problems that are more fundamental to me
or that social media is depressing our
teenagers and if you break up Facebook
into different ownership groups that
actually doesn't impact Iona chicon so
we have to figure out what the actual
problem trying to solve are and then
break them up excuse me I have to go cry
in a safe space thank you very much
everybody
you